bienvenue à tous nouveau podcast pour
vous présenter l'essentiel sur un
prospect de la draft 2023 NBA ce podcast
sera dédié à Chris Murray
Chris Murray le jumeau de Tigan Murray
drafté l'an passé par les sacs àmento
King's donc
comme le veut l'appellation de jumeaux
le même jour le 19 août 2000 donc il
sera vieux au moment de cette draft
bientôt 23 ans 2 m 03 100 kg de mettre
13 d'envergure il jouait à Iowa cette
année nous l'avons vingtième sur notre
big board notre classement des meilleurs
prospects cette saison 20e il est
également chez yatletic yespielle ne
voit 25e meilleur joueur de cette cuvée
25e meilleur prospect plutôt et the
Ringer 27e pour en parler Mathias Thomas
salut messieurs
bonjour à tous
Thomas parle-nous du parcours de Chris
Murray avant son année passée avant ces
années passées à ayoa s'il te plaît
alors va pur produit de la Yoha
christmurray comme son frère comme toute
sa famille il vient de sedarder donc
dans cet état il a fait son parcours
High School après High School pas un top
100 prospect pas vraiment pas un gros
prospect comme son frère tout simplement
des joueurs assez sous côté pendant très
longtemps il vient d'une famille de
basketteur déjà de l'iOS frais son père
pardon Kilian Murray un jeu de 92 à 96
dans la FACA daiha un joueur qui a fait
deux saisons à plus de 10 points par
match donc un joueur intéressant donc
son frère comme on l'a dit son frère
jumeau Tidiane sort d'une très belle
saison avec les Kings où il a pu être
intéressant dans cette équipe Dakine
vous avez eu pas mal de minutes il a pu
jouer ampleur fait montrer des bonnes
choses cette saison Chris Murray et a eu
un peu le même développement
que son frère l'an passé avec un an de
retard entre guillemets il a une
première saison à Yoha et je suis pas du
tout la deuxième saison
il commence à jouer à côté de son frère
son frère brille forcément mais lui est
quasiment un petit point normal je
commence vraiment à avoir un bon temps
de jeu et cette année c'est lui qui est
devenu la star de l'équipe il a joué 35
minutes par rencontre donc c'est très
intéressant c'était un des meilleurs
joueurs du pays un plus de 20 points par
match il a vraiment fait une très très
belle saison il est pas annoncé aussi
frère mais il est quand même annoncé au
premier tour avec ses nombreuses
qualités basket contrairement à son
frère il est gaucher c'est la grande
différence entre les deux et
personnellement j'étais un peu surpris
au combat après son frère jumeau ne
l'avait pas fait mais il était mesuré à
6 7 75 sans chaussures c'est à dire
quelque chose sur on tutoie le 6/9 le 26
donc vraiment très intéressant pour lui
qui arrive qui va donc arriver en NBA
très très sûrement au premier tour cette
année
Mathias qu'est-ce qui Thomas parlait
d'un le rôle de leader offensif cette
année donc en poste quoi en post-4 ok
qu'est-ce qui faisait est-ce qu'on était
sur du pic and pop est-ce que il
initiait de la balle et ce qui joue au
poste comme Killian Murray l'année
dernière que comment se construisait ces
20 points par match bah ils utilisaient
de toutes les manières possibles j'avais
envie de dire
ioa c'est un programme qui cette année
jouait sans réel vrai big à l'intérieur
donc il jouait il jouait quasi post 5
même par séquence
il était utilisé en post-up il était
utilisé en joueur de spot-up il était
joué utilisé en joueur de sortie d'écran
il était vraiment utilisé dans plein de
manières possibles 27% de yoseai donc ce
qui est quand même conséquent il était
il touche les ballons sur chaque
possession offensive forcément on l'a
dit c'est la star de l'équipe c'est une
star de NCIS donc ouais
post-4-5 mais qui sera vraisemblablement
post quatre voire 3 en NBA
et défensivement qui est du coup il
devait se prendre des gros des gros
babares en défense ils défendaient sur
les cinq il était ou alors il était plus
utilisé comme un joueur dead qui a de
l'impact puisqu'il a une grande
envergure et bah du coup comme je disais
il a il y a pas de gros big dans
l'équipe donc c'est il s'est coltiné
souvent des gros babares
même si c'est une équipe Iowa qui défend
qui défend assez bien ensemble avec
beaucoup d'aide c'est lui qui s'est
retrouvé sur les situations de post-up
adverse mais c'est un joueur qui
peut-être est moins moins solide moins
costaud que son frère mais qui peut-être
bouge un peu mieux et plus à même de
défendre sur les sur les postes plus
extérieurs il a une meilleure mobilité
latérale à mes yeux c'est un joueur qui
bouge beaucoup mieux donc il a il s'est
retrouvé aussi à défendre à l'intérieur
et à l'extérieur
ok
qualité la qualité pour pour en citer
une seule pour pour lui pourquoi on le
draft la qualité qui va l'amener en NBA
la qualité de Chris Murray c'est je
dirais que c'est le mot le dessous NBA
c'est un joueur qui a un bon physique
sur l'aile qui comme on l'a dit
quasiment 2 mètres 6 en chaussures qui
fait proches de 200 kg comme son frère
il est plutôt assez dans ce même si
c'est un peu moins costaud un peu moins
impactant sur ce défense au circuit qui
gagne il a une bonne et une bonne
envergure dont elle permet vraiment de
défendre sur l'aile en NBA il y a pas
trop de problèmes là-dessus et on
attaque c'est un genre auquel on va
demander on va demander le shoot à trois
points il tient beaucoup plus à trois
points cette année que son frère avec
une réussite un peu décevante seulement
33,5% à 3 points et sur près de 70
un jour qui met ses trois et c'est un
joueur qui comme son frère un genre
interdit les gens sur le terrain c'est
un joueur qui va faire les choses pour
faire gagner son équipe tout simplement
il va aller se coltiner comme on l'a dit
la bataille à l'intérieur pour aller
chercher ses rebonds il va faciliter le
jeu de son équipe cette année il avait
un rôle plus central ce sera pas du tout
le cas mais il va savoir faire cette
très bonne extrapass c'est parce qu'il
casse quelques lignes pour aller
chercher des tirs ouverts pour ses
partenaires donc ça va être un peu le
swing le genre qui défend le genre qui
met des trois points derrière la ligne
et qui fait facile et qui participent à
l'effort collectif pour la vie de son
équipe tout simplement Mathias une autre
qualité ajoutée ou à compléter
il a beaucoup de qualité c'est dur de
lui trouver un défaut un vrai défaut
chez lui
ouais joueur de catch and shout
excellent catch and shoot je pense que
c'est un vrai joueur qui peut qui peut
shooter de plusieurs manières
différentes à trois points
on l'a pas beaucoup vu au football cette
année mais je pense que c'est un joueur
qui est vraiment capable de jouer à vol
en sortie d'écran et en mouvement
et plutôt intelligent avec la balle
aussi on note quand même assez peu de
balles perdues malgré le taux d'usage
que tu as décrit qui était assez haut
quand il était sur le terrain
donc dans l'ensemble un joueur efficace
alors si on compare avec la saison qui
gagne l'année dernière juste un peu
moins efficace dans chaque catégorie
statistique quasiment surtout
mais mais néanmoins pour les standards
NCIS ça reste très très bon et à part à
trois points c'est vrai que c'est
souvent lui qui se crée son tir
notamment très bon au cercle avec 67% de
réussite et seulement moins de la moitié
des tirs qui viennent d'une A6 et même à
mi distance c'est un 35 % qui est
correct voilà avec beaucoup de
d'autocréations
Mathias comment tu vois le son
développement qu'est-ce que pour toi il
faut travailler en priorité pour Chris
Murray pour gagner sa place dans un
roster en fait
on est quand même pas loin d'un produit
fini je pense avec Chris donc il y aura
pas de grosse grosse marge de
progression à mon avis maintenant là
cette saison il finit à trois points
à 30
donc c'est c'est clairement pas assez ça
s'explique aussi par le nombre de shoots
qui prend et par les les responsabilités
défensives qu'il a et aussi la diversité
des choses qui prend mais en tout cas il
va falloir être plus efficace et plus
constant sur son shoot extérieur si s'il
veut vraiment avoir un impact en NBA
donc si s'il y a une un endroit à
développer c'est son shoot je pense
parce que on le sait capable mais il y a
une petite question en plus il a 72%
lancer franc ce qui est peu donc des
petites réserves
tout à fait
Thomas qu'est-ce que tu qu'est-ce que tu
vois au niveau de la
projection dès l'année prochaine
qu'est-ce qu'on va lui faire faire
c'est un joueur qu'on grave pour le
faire je rapidement je pense on draft un
joueur qui va avoir 23 ans au moment de
sa première année NBA comme on l'a dit
c'est shooter il s'est défendent sans
colle bleue il va aller au rebond il va
faire les bonnes passes donc pour moi si
on draft Chris me reste c'est un joueur
qu'on met rapidement dans dans la
rotation dans sa rotation en fait c'est
un joueur qui doit être qui doit être
notre backup ou un de nos backup sur les
ailes quasiment day one en NBA et on lui
fait faire quoi alors
lui fait faire quoi on lui fait défendre
pas le meilleur attaquant adverse pour
moi comme son frère c'est des défenseurs
intéressants c'est des défenseurs
intelligents mais c'est pas non plus les
stoppeurs du siècle donc pour moi on le
fait défendre sur sur un joueur adverse
sur lequel on l'assigne pas le meilleur
comme je l'ai dit mais l'autre pardon et
offensivement on le fait tirer on le
fait tirer à trois points bien sûr faut
augmenter sa réussite comme la dit
Mathias il y a des écarts par moments
ils sont un petit peu inquiétant je
trouve il est capable de réel gros
écarts on lui fait on lui fait faire les
extrapasses c'est un jour de punchen qui
doit faciliter le jeu de son équipe
j'étais déjà pas très fan de l'obside
handball de tidian Murray sur un un peu
de Jump un peu de jumper de One Two
throuble jumper et pour moi on crée
c'est encore un petit peu moins fort et
en plus il a un nom de plus donc pour
moi qu'il y en aurait même si j'étais
déjà pas fan de l'obside il y en avait
un peu plus que Christ meuren et Chris
Murra un rôle plancher très très
intéressant parfois le player sur elle
en NBA
pas de gros problèmes physique à
signaler on précise sur au niveau de
l'historique et ce qu'il y a est-ce que
tu vois quel meilleur scénario que tu
vois Mathias pour pour Chris Murray le
meilleur scénario pas forcément l'année
prochaine mais à terme quel genre de
joueurs au mieux ça pourrait être je
pense ce sera un joueur similaire à son
frère un jour
un rôle player un rôle player dans une
équipe NBA titulaire je sais pas mais en
tout cas qui aura des tâches de
défensive et mettre des trois points qui
pourra plus défendre sur les poses de 3
que son frère mais en tout cas
défendent sur les ailes mais des trois
points d'attaque mettre des points
d'autres manières parce qu'il est
capable c'est pas le joueur le plus
rapide le plus explosif pour courir vite
pour courir en transition marquée des
points dans un dans un rythme élevé mais
c'est un vrai rôle player je pense il a
un vrai profil de roleplayer qui qui a
peu de chance d'échouer en NBA
et sur le monde la mentalité Mathias sur
les attitudes qu'il avait loin du ballon
quand il était sur le banc est-ce qu'on
voyait sa maturité on voyait un joueur
de 23 ans ouais on le voit que c'est un
leader quand son équipe il a toutes les
responsabilités maintenant après
peut-être parce qu'il a beaucoup de
responsabilités offensives je l'ai vu
surtout of bol défensivement avoir
quelques oublis quelques manques de
concentration maintenant il a pas
forcément défendu dans une zone qui est
dans laquelle il défendra de biais il a
beaucoup défendu dans la raquette par le
manque de pivot de l'équipe
mais mais ouais c'est vrai que j'ai noté
quelques quelques manques de
concentration quelques manques de
compréhension parfois sur des bacs d'or
par exemple donc s'il y a des problèmes
hors-ball je pense qu'ils sont plus
défensifs
ok ok
et bien messieurs est-ce qu'on y croit
ou quoi un peu beaucoup passionnément
Chris Murray est-ce qu'on croit en ça on
sa carrière est-ce qu'il aura une et la
question subsidiaire c'est est-ce qu'il
aura une aussi bonne année rookie que
qui gagne
alors pour moi est-ce qu'on y croit oui
dur de pas y croire au vu de ce qu'il a
montré cette année au vu de la réussite
de son frère l'an dernier qui a fait une
année routier vraiment intéressante
c'est un joueur qui a tout pour pour
réussir et pour faire une longueur NBA
on l'a dit ça je rappelle les gens c'est
un genre qui tire c'est un genre qui
défend il va devoir améliorer ma
storiser son tir pour atteindre le plus
haut niveau possible à mes yeux mais
pour moi il est un peu moins fort que
son frère notamment notamment
offensivement il a un peu moins de
diversité et de facilité pour scorer
donc pour moi c'est un joueur qui est un
peu en dessous de nukiyan mais pas tant
que ça je pense que dans dans le rôle
qu'ils auront en NBA avec des trois
points à défendre il peut vraiment
quasiment tout aussi intéressant et je
pense que ouais rapidement il peut il
peut s'inscrire comme un très bon joueur
d'une d'une rotation NBA c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a tous à peu près dans le même
range chez noir verdure là tout seul
vers vin était poussière parce que c'est
un genre qui
qui est trop qui est trop bon qui est
trop efficace qui a trop un profil NBA
pour pour le laisser tomber malgré
malgré son âge avancé et son plafond
peut-être pas le plus excitant du
premier tour très clairement Mathias
ouais pas pareil dur de pas y croire que
ton profil est très bien maintenant pour
la question est-ce que il aura le même
impact que son frère en est une
Chris Murray sera pas drafté en quatre
en tout cas je pense pas
non je pense peut-être pas qu'il sera
titulaire comme comme Kylian elle a été
à sacrémento dure de faire aussi bien
que que kidiane tant il a mis la barre
haute mais mais ouais il pourra aider
dans une rotation
tout ça de toute façon ce genre de
joueurs qui qui est pas handicapant pour
une équipe et qui dans son rôle va faire
ce qu'on lui demande tout simplement
marquer marquer et puis et puis faire le
minimum
[Musique]
jumeaux monozygote de Tigan Chris Murray
était donc l'objet de ce podcast vous
avez tous les autres tous les candidats
qui sont vus au premier tour de cette
draft NBA 2023 premier tour top 20 allez
sur votre plateforme d'écoute préférée
on est présent sur l'intégralité de ces
plateformes sur Youtube également et
vous avez les résumés écrits des points
forts faibles de chaque joueur sur
envergure.co salut tout le monde